[Musique]
vous est il déjà arrivé de parler pour
ne rien dire
ce moment où vous vous trouvez face à
votre interlocuteur que vous ne
connaissez pas beaucoup et vous essayer
tant bien que mal de combler le vide
pour éviter d'avoir à vous regarder dans
le blanc des yeux
prenons un exemple de lycéens vous vous
souvenez certainement tous de ses
premiers à lunettes qui la fin du cours
venus se précipiter sur le professeur
pour lui demander des renseignements
complémentaires
bon je faisais partie de ses premiers sa
lunette mais on attention en allant
consulter les professeurs n'étaient pas
temps d'approfondir le court que de les
persuader de mon intérêt pour leur
matière afin qu'ils m'apprécient mieux
et me donne de meilleures notes
cependant lorsque j'étais face à
l'enseignant et qu'il délivre une
réponse passionnés à mes cours de
questions je n'arrivais pas à l'écouté
préoccupé par l'image qu'il aurait deux
mois pour me concentrer sur ses paroles
je le dévisageait en essayant de
paraître le plus intéressé possible
ponctuant ses discours de huy et de ah
bon mais au fond sans bien comprendre ce
qu'il voulait dire et cette situation
était insupportable
j'étais très embarrassée car je me
demandais à quel moment il allait
terminer sa réponse à quel moment il
était le plus légitime de partir si ma
question lui avait plu je fais c'est
moins attention à ceux qui le disaient
qu'à la manière dont il ne percevait pas
de contenu que de la forme
j'avais l'impression d'être tenus dans
cette interaction par une main invisible
et de n'avoir qu'à subir des forces
extérieures sur lesquels je n'avais
aucune prise si je vous raconte ce petit
épisode ingrat sais pas pour vous
raconter ma vie c'est juste que je pense
que ce petit exemple met en lumière un
vice énorme que nous avons tous et
contre lequel je vais essayer de vous
proposer quelques solutions l'embarras
j'aimerais insister sur la manière dont
je viens de qualifier l'embarras un vice
énorme
plus qu'une attitude anodine il me
semble que l'embarras est un véritable
vis un vice de forme comme une pièce mal
assemblé qui ferait s'effondrer le plus
solide des meubles l'embarras nous
empêchent souvent d'agir nous fait
manquer des occasions et nous fait
regretter souvent
imaginez par exemple que vous êtes un
cocktail autour d'une personne très
influente et à qui vous avez quelque
chose de très intéressant et de très
importants à dire vous prenez votre
courage à deux mains
vous vous dirigez gaillardement vers
cette personne mais au dernier moment
lorsque vous êtes enfin face à face
après vous êtes serrer la main
vous n'êtes plus capable de prononcer un
mot le projet extraordinaire dont vous
aviez lui parler devient une patte
d'arguments flasque dans laquelle vous
vous noyez la personne fronce les
sourcils s'excuse poliment et tourne la
tête vers une autre personne qu'elle
voit passer vous venez peut-être de
perdre une occasion de donner un nouvel
élan à votre vie uniquement parce que
vous étiez embarrassé l'embarras nous
empêchent d'agir logiquement et
moralement car ils obstruent une autre
logique et notre moral c'est comme une
pierre qui vient boucher notre
raisonnement et nous renvoie un état
animal qui nous interdit d'agir
à cet égard maîtriser les interactions
sociales peut nous avantager énormément
dans la vie privée autant que
professionnel et nous empêcher de
commettre de graves erreurs et c'est de
cette maîtrise dont je veux vous parler
la première question que j'aimerais vous
poser est la suivante d'où vient ce
malaise pourquoi sommes-nous parfois
incapables de maîtriser notre
comportement réfléchissons ensemble
je pense que vous serez d'accord avec
moi sur ce point on est souvent très mal
à l'aise lorsque nous parlons à une
personne à qui nous n'avons pas
l'habitude de parler
imaginez par exemple que vous faites le
trajet menton marseille en train qui
dure environ quatre heures et que vous
vous trouvez face à votre actrice
préférée
qu'est ce que vous lui diriez
que vous lui parleriez des dernières
élections ou est-ce que vous la
complimente aurier sur son dernier film
a priori la solution logique serait
plutôt la seconde si vous l'admirer en
quelque sorte vous trouveriez dommage de
lui trouver de lui parler d'un sujet
aussi banal que les dernières élections
et comme c'est une personne que vous
connaissez et qui ne vous connaît pas
vous n'avez pas forcément quelque chose
de très substantiels à lui dire ainsi
vous ne lui parleriez pas comme si
c'était votre ami vous n'êtes donc pas
dans une situation de communication
authentique vous voulez que cette
actrice se rappelle de vous vous êtes
donc plutôt dans une situation de marché
vous lui donnez des compliments et vous
attendez sa bénédiction en retour vous
voyez cette actrice à l'écran comme une
comédienne que vous appréciez face à
vous comme un juge impitoyable dans
cette situation vous dessinez des rôles
à chacun des personnages
vous êtes le petit passants et elle est
la grande célébrité dans son livre les
rites de l'interaction le sociologue
erving goffman donne les colleurs
intéressante à ces jeux de personnalités
sa thèse est que dans ce genre
d'interaction inégale tout le monde se
sent mal à l'aise car chacun essaie de
remplir son rôle le mieux possible
vous remplissez votre rôle de fans en
couvrant l'acteur lectrice de
compliments et elle remplit son rôle de
célébrités en essayant d'être gentil et
en vous remerciant répétitivement avec
un sourire embarrassé
vous vivez cette situation comme un
grand oral alors que vous n'êtes que
dans un simple voyage en train et bien
c'est exactement le même problème
qu'avec mes professeurs de lycée dont il
faut parler au début on ne s'intéresse
pas du tout vos contenus seulement à la
forme maintenant
rappelez vous la question que je vous ai
posé au début de ce premier point
pourquoi sommes nous si mal à l'aise
lorsque nous parlons à des personnes que
nous connaissons peut peut-être qu'après
ce premier point de réflexion ne sommes
plus à même d'y répondre
nous créons une situation de marché avec
la personne car nous attendons quelque
chose d'elle
ainsi nous essayons de remplir le rôle
que semble nous attribuer la situation
délaissant ainsi notre capacité à
improviser à plaisanter et à profiter
nous voici au pied du mur bloqué dans
nos élans lyriques par ce poids du
regard de l'autre
et à chaque fois que nous en prenons
conscience nous sommes très malheureux
mais nous sommes incapables de sortir de
cette prison
pourtant au fond de notre enfermement je
vois un petit chemin éclairé presque
invisible et qui mène à la liberté dans
ce petit chemin se divisent de sentiers
la poursuite de ses buts et la recherche
du bonheur c'est 206 ement au même
endroit la communication tranquille
non entrons dans ce petit chemin et
empruntons le premier sentier la
poursuite de ses buts
avoir un objectif précis permet d'être
beaucoup plus à l'aise pourquoi
simplement parce que notre esprit n'est
pas encombré par le regard de l'autre
nous pensons à une seule chose et nous
n'avons pas le temps de penser au reste
et tout ce qui arrive autour n'est que
du bonus
exemple vous êtes toujours dans le train
avec l'autre actrice préférée vous
l'appréciez toujours autant vous êtes
dans le même carré famille rien n'a
changé à l'exception d'une chose vous
êtes inquiet car vous avez de gros
soucis professionnels
en effet vous êtes le pdg de faire ma
poule
une entreprise d'abattage de poulets et
vous êtes au bord de la liquidation
judiciaire à cause d'une ong sos poulet
qui ne cesse de mener campagne contre
vous pourtant vous êtes parfaitement aux
normes vous poulets sont élevés dans des
conditions sanitaires très
scrupuleusement contrôlés et vos clients
sont satisfaits vous remuer votre esprit
sur la manière de vous dépêtrer de cette
situation
quand tout en vous apercevez face à vous
votre actrice préférée et présidente de
l' ong sos poulet sans hésiter vous lui
dit avec un sourire vous allez à
marseille elle vous répond en souriant
non paris et vous lui dites je m'arrête
à cannes pour le festival et ainsi de
suite
vous savez pertinemment qu'au bout de
deux minutes de conversation banale vous
allez parler de poulet et de manière
très sérieuse mais votre objectif est
très clair et très important vous voulez
garder votre emploi est votre position
vous ne le perdez donc jamais de vue et
vous faites tout pour l'atteindre
ainsi votre discours ne se perd pas vous
ne gagnez pas car vous ne cherchez pas à
impressionner la personne qui est en
face de vous vous cherchez simplement a
entamé tranquillement la conversation et
ainsi vous êtes parfaitement maître de
l'interaction vous êtes trop préoccupé
par votre but pour vous laisser
soumettre par les déterminismes dont
nous parlait erding hoffman dans les
rites de l'interaction ici il n'ya plus
de rôles plus de forme que du contenu
vous voulez continuer à vendre des
poulets et votre admiration pour
l'actrice s'efface au profit de votre
but
le travail
revenons sur nos pas et essayons de
rendre un thé le deuxième chantier la
poursuite du bonheur chercher à être
heureux permet de profiter au maximum
d'une situation
ce que je veux dire ici c'est quand même
si on n'a pas d'objectif précis
il faut oublier tous les rôles que l'on
joue dans l'interaction et se laisser
guider par ce dont on a envie voici le
sentier qui mène à la liberté
d'interagir authentiquement reprenant
encore notre exemple de l'actrice dans
le train vous êtes en train de lire
votre livre tranquillement à votre place
quand elle vient s'asseoir en face de
vous dans un premier temps vous allez
absolument vouloir lui parler pour
profiter de l'occasion pour être reconnu
mais la meilleure solution serait plutôt
de lui parler si vous avez quelque chose
d'intéressant à lui dire et de continuer
à lire votre livre si vous n'avez rien
d'intéressant à lui dire ça paraît d'une
outrageuse évidence oui mais pas
nécessairement on a tous envie de
marquer le coup de paraître intelligent
de lâcher nos activités quotidiennes
pour surfer dans l'exceptionnel eh bien
à mon sens le plus important est de bien
raisonner et de se dire dans quelle
situation
vais-je être le plus heureux ou la plus
heureuse en parlant avec cette actrice
ou en continuant à lire mon livre
cette capacité de juger et le meilleur
des guides vers une maîtrise de
l'interaction nous ne sommes plus soumis
aux forces qui donne à l'actrice un rôle
dominant et à nous un rôle de fans
nous sommes simplement en train de lire
un livre avec la possibilité si le coeur
vous en dit de discuter avec notre
intéressante voisine d'en face à cet
égard le philosophe andré gide sera
beaucoup plus clair que moi dans son
chef-d'oeuvre les nourritures terrestres
manuel de la vie agréable dont le
refrain et lâche ce livre et oublie moi
il dit je cite chaque
on part fait sa compagne de volupté à
cela tu connais que tu devais la faire
je n'aime point ceux qui se font un
mérite d'avoir péniblement un vrai car
si c'était pénible
il aurait mieux fait de faire autre
chose la joie que l'on y trouve et signe
de l'appropriation du travail et la
sincérité de mon plaisir mais le plus
important des guides 26 tation vous
pouvez
me reprocher quelque chose quelque chose
d'important
vous pouvez me dire oui mais moi je n'y
arrive pas à profiter parfaitement d'une
situation si je suis face à mon acteur
préféré je vais forcément avoir envie de
lui parler et si je ne mets force à ne
pas le faire je vais être frustré je ne
pourrais rien faire d'autre mais en même
temps si je lui parle je vais être
terriblement mal à l'aise donc tout ce
raisonnement ne sert à rien je suis
bloqué vient probablement de ce
raisonnement ne sert à rien si l'on
ajoute un élément essentiel la confiance
en soi
notre problème essentiel quand nous
parlons à une personne c'est que nous
faisons le malin imaginons rencontre un
grand professeur d'université que l'on
admire et qu'on laborde en parlons son
langage et en le louant au professeur
jean étienne perrigault de marquinho
j'admire votre thèse sur la
psychopathologie des grandes puissances
d'ailleurs je trouve que la russie
présente une schizophrénie aiguë sur le
plan de 6 des dynamiques militaire et
c'est ce que nous faisons là c'est que
nous essayons de gagner la
reconnaissance de la personne à qui nous
parlons en s'adaptant à son langage que
nous ne maîtrisons pourtant pas mais
comme ce langage et le point que nous
attirons chez ce professeur nous
essayons de le reproduire car nous
pensons que c'est son critère pour juger
de la valeur d'une personne
or personne n'aime que les autres
fassent comme soit au contraire on aime
briller par son originalité et être
surpris par des comportements différents
dès lors la confiance en soi ça ne veut
pas dire sandra c'est dans la glace la
confiance en soi c'est ne pas avoir peur
de ce qu'on a à dire et le dire parler
avec ses mots au risque de sembler
ridicule ce qui est un peu
ce n'est pas la manière dont on
s'exprime mais l'assurance avec laquelle
on s'exprime et ainsi on crée une
nouvelle norme
moi je parle comme ça et c'est normal
parce que c'est moi et même si on est
très spécial très marginal ou très
timide
si l'on prononce nos trois mots
quotidien en se concentrant sur notre
pensée et non sur notre manière de
l'exprimer alors ces trois mots seront
nécessairement percutant et cela parce
que tout le monde a le droit d'être
crédible on croit que certaines
personnes sont plus convaincantes que
d'autres mais c'est faux
chacun à son heure d'éloquence et son
heure de silence même les personnes
qu'on voit se débattre sur une estrade
avec la sensation de changer le monde ne
peuvent rien avoir à dire dans un avis
en acteur dans le train un grand
professeur d'économie peut être
embarrassé quand on lui demande la
recette des crêpes la sincérité nous
permet en montrant que nous sommes
imparfaits comme tout le monde
de dessiner un terrain des z entente
avec notre interlocuteur - on a l'air
parfait et plus on al'air audible et
c'est cela le dernier escaliers qui
mènent à la liberté de communiquer
authentiquement la confiance en soi
savoir se hisser en haut d'une tour de
sérénité de laquelle vous toise et le
regard de vos détracteurs savoir penser
ce que vous dites
en oubliant comment vous le dites j'ai
beaucoup parlé mais qu'est ce que j'ai
essayé de vous dire
j'ai voulu vous illustrer ces handicaps
de l'embarras et vous montrer que en
plus d'être un simple désagrément c'est
un véritable handicap quelque chose qui
nous freine qui nous empêchent d'agir
mais si je parle devant vous aujourd'hui
c'est bien que je suis fermement
convaincu que ce handicap peut s'annuler
par un simple renversement d'esprit je
pense que pour être à l'aise dans une
situation une seule chose est nécessaire
s'efforcer de profiter en regardant avec
recul
l'intérêt ou le bonheur que l'on peut
tirer d'une situation on oublie son
malaise et on se concentre sur ce qui
nous intéresse
et c'est en étant intéressés qu'on
devient intéressant retenons donc cela
pour toutes les fois où nous nous
sentirons mal à l'aise au lieu de
s'accrocher aux mots accrochons-nous vos
pensées au lieu de cueillir un discours
au lieu de mûrir un discours que lyon
celui qui vient je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]